hey everyone it's Mike and this video is
about the Delta scalper and particularly
the Delta scalper running on not n t8
now recently I've got I've been in a
couple conversations with some users
about settings and what settings I
prefer to use what settings other people
use and you know how can it help improve
their trading now I don't wanna say it
really depends on what market you're
looking at because I like to I believe
that for an indicator to be legitimate
it has to work in different markets on
different time frames you can't say oh
this indicator only works on crude oil
on a 30 second chart you know I mean
that that's over time that's not going
to be very good very strong because what
you're doing is you're just taking a
period in the past and you're basically
curve fitting your system around that
period is like you just found it happen
you just happen to find the one time
period that it worked on for sure for a
while okay but again for something to be
good and work over time and be
successful in the long long haul it's
got to work on different markets over
different time frames different chart
types with the same settings you know
you can't say well in this market I only
use this setting or this market I only
use this setting no it's it's not going
to be very effective over the long haul
and as a trader that's what being
successful is about surviving the long
haul not a short period of time so when
you load up the Delta scalper and you
click on the indicator you'll see the
properties here there's look back bar so
the ones you really need to be concerned
with are just the period the properties
up in here so look back bar is negative
Delta a positive Delta strength you
don't really need to be concerned with
signal box height that's just that that
just deals with how the indicator fires
on your chart signal box opacity you
know depends how darker you want it I
think the default is set to 20 sometimes
I you know depending on what background
you set your chart to you may want it a
little bit darker you may want it a
little bit lighter if you use a white
background you may want a little bit
darker signal box with
that's how far you want this box to draw
out now that that's really important if
you like to play pull backs right so you
want to know within certain lot of bars
if you're gonna get a pullback or you
know if you're playing it as support or
resistance what is signal mark
displacement - it's just how far off the
top of the bar you want that signal only
on higher this would be that's higher
highs or lower lows if you put your
cursor over it and I'll explain that in
a minute that goes back to the look-back
bars so if you disable it you can get a
lot more signals than if you just if you
have it enabled so here I disabled it so
you can see how it's going to look here
in a second just close that down so
you'll see there's gonna be a ton more
signals basically popping up when it
comes up
it's got how many date I think on this
one I've got several weeks of data on
the chart so it takes a while to go back
through the data to read it but once you
load your chart is there it's not gonna
you know keep recalculating or anything
and since if you have it appearing if
you disable that button not on higher
highs or lower lows I said you're gonna
get a lot more signals and that's why
it's taking a lot longer for it to load
right up in here I don't want to pause
there there you go cuz if I pause it you
know then you won't see how long it took
so it took about 20 seconds you can see
how you're getting all these signals in
here and I'll say that's going to be a
heck of a lot more confusing maybe if
you're a pure scalper now this is a
emini five range chart and you know it's
not every signal you'd be taking a short
on you'd be following it you know you
get long hair then got a short short you
know get short again you know it really
depends on your trading style me I don't
like it I like to use it as a reversal
indicator
so if you're going to use it as a
reversal indicator you go back into the
settings and you click that box there
and then that's going to read this box
up here look back bars look back bars
you could set default is set to seven I
believe but if you use a higher number
so here right I'm going to use 25 it's
going to look back over the last 25 bars
and it's got to be a higher high or a
lower low so you click OK and you'll see
what appears of anything let's give it a
second here
okay again it's got to do the
calculations over that whole period so
if you're using like a three you know if
you're just looking back over the last
couple days then it'll pair really fast
I said I've got several weeks of data
it's got to go through it all before
it'll pop up on the chart but again I
don't want to just pause this video
while it's doing I want you to see in
real time so you're feeling of how long
it can take or not take so there you go
okay so again this is a so again it's
illicit today's Thursday July 5th it's
around 9:30 in the morning right now and
you can see and five range chart you
know it's going back you can see a lot
less signals when you have that filter
on and again I'm looking for you know
potential reversals in the market you
know so let me get this nice trade here
it's some kind of go sideways kind of go
sideways again you catch this nice move
down here are you talking 27:32 area all
the way down to the 27 low 27
20 that's a 10-point move now there are
days don't get you know don't get a
hard-on thinking that every day is gonna
be like this way some days where you
struggle you have you know take a loss
here and depend on where your stop is
maybe took a loss maybe you didn't you
know me I like to keep my stops tight
you know I'm looking for the pure
reversal you know but you know if you
get long at oh six taking it maybe up to
in here at 12 you know you got the pull
back down here we're gonna get one
higher but again it depends on your
trading plan and how you're trading it I
don't want to say you have to trade it
this way because you know there are
people that like to trade it like this
you know they know they got a level here
and they'll throw offers in up in here
waiting for the pullback to come up in
here to get short again rather than just
being aggressive and getting long or
short right after the signals given you
know like err you know they get you got
a sell signal here they just throw an
offer back in here you know the 30 I
don't that is 38 39 level you know and
comes down five points now this one wins
opt out if you got aggressive you know
if you looking for a pullback
immediately in here you're not gonna get
it in this bar off this signal but then
if you're not aggressive you missed the
trade me I like to be a little bit more
aggressive but again I depend on your
training style and your training plan
more importantly so this is a five range
chart now you know the other question I
get is well which chart type is better
is it a minute pace chart or range based
chart or what and you know me I prefer
range based charts because I like to see
how price moves from one price level to
another price level rather than it's you
know ten twenty one okay now it's time
to form a new bar because I'm looking at
a one minute chart let's take a look at
a one minute chart here again same
settings that I'm using on the
one-minute chart they see how the
one-minute chart pops up in here again
give it a against it's still got to go
through the calculations for the
indicator over the last 15 days of data
that I have loaded on this chart so it's
gonna take a few minutes so again you
know this is how it looks on a 1-minute
chart now honestly you know that for me
when treating a contract like the e-mini
x' you know can you trade it it
overnight session yes you can but
obviously you know it's gonna be a big
difference in volume you can see how
this is the evening session granted this
was July 4th you know coming into July
5th in here so this is July 5th evening
or morning session you know 6:00 in the
morning whereas you can see here at 8:30
how much bigger the bars are you know
there's just a heck of a lot more volume
and when you're dealing with Delta you
know it's probably better to have more
data than than less data because you
know if you're looking at you know some
bars may have a delta of 20 like you
know that this time at night at 11
o'clock you know 11:30 midnight if I
getting even only getting signals or
just reading the Delta you know that the
underlying volume is not as great during
the day now is that to say it's better
or worse again you know that that's up
for you to decide and and on how you
trade
you know you do get good signals though
you know in the evening session
sometimes but again you know Europe you
know sometimes you get very thin volume
and like here sometimes you get very
nice volume and ranges but again it
really depends on on your trading style
you know and how you trade how you
approach the market you know there's no
one right way to approach the market you
know sometimes you know people get so
caught up and trying to find the right
timeframe
you know that's it there is a trade a
five-minute chart they'll take a bunch
of losses and say well I got a dig
deeper I get the microscope bought the
next thing that you know they're looking
at a one minute chart or a thirty second
chart and they're not sticking to what
they know and you know their own
psychological makeup because you know if
you're trading a longer timeframe you
try to go to a shorter timeframe you're
going to struggle because you're going
to overanalyze things and in the markets
move much differently on a 1 minute time
frame than they do on a 5 minute time
frame so now another change I want to
talk about not change but another
setting you can you can mess around with
so to speak is the Delta strength so
default is set to 1 you can change it to
whatever you want to 3 it's got to be a
whole number so it's like 2 3 4 5 now to
go from 1 to 2 you're doubling it so if
you made it 3 you'd be doubling 2 so
it'd actually be a strength of you know
if the Delta would be four times as
stronger and and so on so you know go to
8 I'm sorry if you changed it to 4 it'd
be you know 8 times as strong so it's
it's doubling it each time you go up now
you know recently I was talking to
somebody about the Delta strength of of
2 and you know as you make the Delta
stronger you're gonna get less signals
and again what's better for you you know
do you want more signals you want less
signals and you know if you go with it
if you're somebody that needs a lot of
action so to speak you know if you start
making it higher higher higher
you're gonna get less signal so you can
get less you know less signals less
activity but again you can see here it's
slightly different
in terms of the amount of signals you
know on this day you had some nice
signals really nice signals you know you
got this buy right off this hello here
at the o6 area you know the way up into
the 20s and you know sometimes you know
people will send me a chart and they'll
be like oh look at this you know it
didn't give any nice winters in here or
you know gave the cell signal here then
came stopped out you know all your
scamming me because you know they
sometimes for some reason people expect
every trade to be a winner and that's
the wrong way to approach trading not
every trade you're ever going to take is
going to be a winning trade you know
there's so many factors outside your
control you don't know when you get
short right in here you think this is a
great trading opportunity and then BOOM
you know for whatever reason in order
hits the desk at goldman sachs to pie
5,000 d minis and no matter what you're
doing you're going to be you can't beat
it right and you don't know when it's
going to happen but that's sort of the
unknown factor in trading there's a lot
of unknowns out there so you can see
here it's set to two now there's there's
a bit less signals this is July 4th July
3rd rather the day before 4th of July
you know so wasn't that great done that
day you know in the evening session on
July 4th you know you had the early
close you know I gave some ok signals ok
I don't know what it's looking like this
morning this is the evening session
going to July 5th here so you had this
one buy signal it didn't work you know
not every trade is going to be a nice 20
point winner you'd like it but that's
just not how things work no you know
that's you know compare that to say 5
range chart and see how it looks
again you know what's what's people say
well what should I use I use a range
based charge that I use a minute face
charge it depends on you you know you
trade the chart type that you're
comfortable with you know so like I can
hear you know just sort of went sideways
there again this is with the setting set
at to the Delta strength set it to say
see a lot less signals when it's set it
to all right you only see a handful of
signals this data's on going back to
July first though but you just seen a
lot less signals are they more accurate
not necessarily you know I mean you got
winter and winter winter you know then
you got a winter air kind of a sideways
there this one might say no even though
let's start out as a winner this one no
and this morning eventually start
starting to go in that direction but
again you know where are you placing
your stop if you're getting short and
you know aggressively in here at 26 yeah
I wouldn't take it all the way up to 30
I want to take a four-point risk and
even though you know it's got the
potential to go down you know down into
the 20s and low 20s again you know you
got to be smart about your stop
placements and you know for me I'd
probably place it just right up in here
I would have been stopped out then I
would not take four points of risk on a
five ranging mini chart so again you
know it's understanding your risk so
yeah just really quick let's take a look
at it at another chart I'll go back to a
minute based chart give it a second here
then off throw in the crude oil this so
again the other settings or screwed
[Music]
I can't get a second here
this is crude oil so one minute chart
again the settings were looked back at
25 Delta strength the two positive and
two negative so you can see here you got
a little bit of a pop up here this one
failed that one failed you know this
morning though you got this nice winner
from in here from the 73-72 area all the
way up to the 90s you know right on the
reopen you had a sell the other day
before what day was that I don't know
you know this one started to work out
came back up here before fell out of bed
in the morning you know these just sort
of going sideways not much happening in
here but this was the trade you wanted
you know from the 7375 area all the way
up into this you know above 7410 okay
now now let's now you see this big move
here
I'm just curious when you you know this
is when you're starting to deal with the
Delta strength you know sometimes you're
gonna catch moves if you set it at one
that you wouldn't otherwise catch if if
you had it set at at two I don't know if
it's gonna catch this move or not but
we'll see you know I'm always may have
may have given you a buy right in here
for all I know but again you know that's
why you got to play you're gonna have
some decent stuff I didn't catch the
home we caught it a little bit earlier
before with the Delta strength of two it
had the sell signal back here you'll see
it got a little bit of a move before it
fell out of bed this one failed
obviously that's 625 Chicago time you
know catch a move
catch this move seventy three seventy
all the way up to 74 hundred you know so
it's giving you some decent signals this
on a 1-minute chart I'll just go back
here
forward so this is this morning right
now so now let's compare it to say a 5
minute chart
yeah because again you know people
always saying about what's the better
chart you know I trade a five-minute
chart you know sometimes you know people
get they have already a chart type that
they trade and you know they want to
stick with it and and see if it's if
it's going to work or not
basically so let's see here it's got to
go back through the data it's still
calculating I can tell when it's
calculating when I move the chart
whatever you call it they're digging
here so again you know on on the
five-minute chart it caught that move
7460 down to 73 bucks then you didn't
get on the other chart you know here
yeah you know give you a short then you
get stopped out here you're just one
started to work out then it failed so
you know you catch we've caught that
move just go back it's when I reloaded
this chart it's not giving me just a few
days instead of the whole fifteen days
but the other important thing to keep in
mind is you have to enable this you have
a click tick replay that's very
important because if you don't have it
ticked enabled then nothing's going to
happen you're not gonna get any
indications on your chart at all but you
have to enable tick replace so they do
the historical data for the order flow
will be accurate and it can run the
analysis properly so let's see how it's
let's go back again you know another
week another 10 days rather and see how
it worked out again you know I mean
looking back over one or two days isn't
always useful you want to go back as
many days as possible to get a good
accurate depiction of what you're
looking at and then what you're gonna be
basing your training decisions on so
again it's just doing its calculations
against a five-minute chart
hmm nothing yet
you know I could tell that's still
calculating just because it has this
this cursor here is working there
okay
so let's going back up a bit longer you
know a five-minute chart again me me
personally and I don't trade a
five-minute chart but you know people
were asking me how it looks on 5-minute
chart so I wanted to show you show it to
you cuz yeah I'm not the type of person
that would get long ear at what is that
like seven you know 7 p.m. at night and
hold it all the way up until 7:00 in the
morning that that's I don't have the
time to do that I'm more of a I was a
hit-and-run trader running on somebody
that's just going to be dinner and outs
as as quickly as possible so just go
back to this settings when they were set
at this was one yeah so one one in 25
one and one now again you know when it
comes down to range based charts you
know people say well what's the best
range of each chart to use you know most
people are familiar with minute based
charts you know show you is a one-minute
chart a five-minute chart again you know
when you're dealing with range based
charts you know five range eight range
10 range for most markets I stick to
either a 4 range or 5 range like emini
snps and in grains you know most grains
I stick to a 4 range chart because you
know it moves in quarters and a quarter
four quarters equals a dollar but I'm
crude I prefer an eighth range chart
because it's a little bit more volatile
than you know some of these these other
markets like like grains but again it
comes down to you what you're
comfortable with I know some people that
like to use a three range chart on crude
oil and it leaves me scratching my head
because I'm like now that's very fast
you know how can you you know you kind
of be like not a robot but you got to be
able to make your decisions very quickly
and you know a lot of people are slow I
mean know if you have it programmed in
there the
to fire off you know buys or sells as
soon as the bar is closed okay then what
if you're manually clicking I think
you're going to be left way way behind
the curve so this is an 8 range chart
this is it's set at 1 you know is there
some signals yeah you got some you know
again you're getting a by getting stuff
out here in the cell you get this by you
get stopped out you got this cell again
where you place your stop maybe you're
not stopped out
yeah nice by here got a nice cell here
nice little by here this this one was
stuff y'all and then again you know the
difference between you know the range
based chart and a metaphase chart as
well as when you're dealing with a range
based chart you know one bar can be
formed in five seconds well you're not
gonna get down a minute base chart
because you know it's it's restricted to
constricted to the time you know if
you're on a non minute chart you need 60
seconds when I arranged based chart it's
moving bars are forming as prices moving
so if you're in a fast market situation
and you're covering you know 50 cents
over five seconds you know you'll have
what is that five or six bars being
formed in that five seconds and that's
what I'm talking about being fast like
in this move how long it took but just
really you know just expanded a bit here
you know 8:01 8:02 it's gone from you
know seventy three sixty basically all
the way up to you know seventy three
seventy five but you over the time
period it's it's how many R's it's you
know three bars and you get times like
that with you know when you're dealing
with with range based charts you're not
going to obviously see on base charts
just because of you know how its formed
so you know that's that's a delta
scalper and again you know it's designed
for futures you know it's the data that
comes out of the cma exchange is
different than the data you're gonna get
for for X so if you're trading Forex you
know it might be different I mean if
you're trading Forex you could trade
euro currency it's let's take a look at
the euro currency contract here the 6e
the
futures contract on the euro versus the
dollar I mean you can trade that you
don't necessarily need to be restricted
to trading you know fxcm or you know any
other brokerage thinking that oh you
know that's like I can only trade Forex
through there no I mean you can trade it
on you can trade the futures contracts
so what is the society this is one you
know I mean you can say you get some
decent signals yeah be getting some
decency those 166 you know 50 you know I
live to the close here at ten you know
you do get stopped out in here this one
was stopped you got started to con your
favor and stopped you out again started
going your favorite stop throughout
again you know this time just looking at
the last two what is that July 3rd
basically the last two days more or less
but again you know that's what the
setting at one if you were to set the
setting again this is a range base chart
if you set the setting at - you probably
get slightly less signals I don't know
if they're better I haven't looked
recently at this chart on a setting the
- but I'm sure you're going to get fewer
signals so yeah so you instead of
getting all those crappy signal you got
those too but you know instead of
getting the the one that failed or
earlier you just have this one here at
10 o'clock now this is where you got to
play a little defense in there can't
pull preservation you know you've got
this nice trade here this one worked out
a bit again you know what's your trading
plan that's what a lot of traders just
grew up basically is they don't have a
trading plan in place so they don't know
how to react when the market does this
you should be getting out don't sit here
wait no I'm gonna wait for it to come
back you know if you're not pullback
trader you're not gonna catch you know
you're gonna get stopped out here you
know it if you pull back trader you're
not gonna get filled here if you're
aggressive you'll get you'll get in as
soon as this bar closes and you can
catch the you know the 15 point move 15
tick move your pullback trader you know
maybe you're getting short in here you
know with the stop
up here you have a tighter stop but you
know no matter what if you're a pullback
trader you get stopped out here if your
aggressive trader even get stopped out
here so again it really depends on your
trading style and you as a trader you
know I mean not not every day is going
to be you know this this nice monster
move you know it's it really really
varies you know on the type of trading
that you do and you know the type of
chart that you look at you know you have
to think of you know each type of chart
in each you know each timeframe is a
different training plan okay you're
training a minute pace chart you can't
necessarily have the exact same stop
levels that you would have on an
arranged base chart on range base chart
you know what the levels you know what a
bar how big a bar is going to be on a
minute they start you don't know you get
some bars that are three ticks and you
get other bars that are you know 13
ticks there's a difference of 10 ticks
basically and you know if you're not you
know not aware of that not cognizant of
that then and you're gonna miss out
you're gonna you're gonna struggle in
your training cuz you can be taking
bigger losses then then you should
because you're gonna take it either more
or you're going to be taken you're going
taking a more frequent losses or you're
going to be taking bigger losses in the
sense that your stop is going to be
blown out now again you know people is
what I'm talking about pullback that's
why we draw at this zone because we're
looking for you know people I'd like to
play pull backs like to play pull back
into the zone they just throw bins in
here you know because they're looking at
this is the area where aggressive buying
started happening that caused the Delta
scalper to give it by and you get this
pullback in here so you know they're
looking for the buying with what their
thought processes is okay the market is
just it's coming off here and all you're
trying to get some aggressive buying
coming in Delta's scalper kicks off
gives you a buy okay market popped up
now again you know the big buyers the
ones that are causing the Delta scalper
to give a signal they're just not gonna
continue buying you know they're gonna
buy then they're gonna let the market
breathe and come back down in here but
this is that area this is there
their target that they were looking to
start buying yet then you know it starts
getting aggressive again boom starts
moving up comes we let it breathe again
boom starts moving back up again so you
can see if you were patient right and
you're looking to to buy you know you
can buying it down here at 48 you know
it's rally in 10 ticks up in here to 58
but again you know it really depends on
your trading style that big bar there
you know me I tend to stay away from
these types of hearts but even if you
said holy come only I get in you got in
here at 26 took a little bit heat down
here at 20 you could have wrote it up
here toward gave a sell signal 36 you
know again you know if you're looking
for the pullback it was its top shot you
know when you're trading pullback so
I'll still gotta have stops in there you
know it's kinda like immediately gonna
pull back then go pick up some ties are
gonna keep going lower it's gonna fall
apart because that buying that was there
earlier it's no longer there you know
this is essentially because this level
when you scoot it out here comes out to
almost that same level but again you
know this was the nice trade you have
here from 30 all the way up to 40 you
know instantly almost face chart again
you know you getting some signals in
here you know again it's it's like this
I see how it is this line is holding you
know if I were to draw this out you
could draw this out here like this
there's my drawing tools that's six so
you draw that out there right so you
know if you're looking to buy between
these two lines right you can see how it
just comes right back down in here right
and it's holding kind of curious up here
again just touch that line up in here
before it's sold off again it came down
here poke down through here and then
rally back up again you know these are
the trades you know if you're a patient
and you're willing to sit here going and
wait for that you know like a hunter
stocking the market then you're buying
it in here you can have a very tight
stop you know this is what 117 ten and a
half right in here between ten and a
half and eleven and a half so you're
buying it in here at eleven
you got a three ticks top down here at
well this is moves in half ticks so you
know we'll call it four take city by
night at eleven you got to stop down
here at nine what's nine that is
probably nine so you got to stop down in
here at nine you know imagine you're
able to buy it at eleven
can't you move all the way up into the
you know 21:22 area right up in here
before it pulls back I'm not saying oh
yeah you would've bought it here and
sold it up here nah that's but
you know first major pullback right here
is probably where you would have covered
you know find it at 11 getting on at 22
23 you know that's a nice trade you know
you take that you'd be risking three
ticks to get you know twenty twenty two
ticks cuz moves in half ticks so again
you know this video went a bit longer
than I expected but I hope this answers
some of your questions on the Delta
scalper and and how to use it how to
play around with the settings but again
you know I don't very very the settings
and I try to keep the settings so I'm
like three things you really gotta mess
around with is a look-back filter if you
want it on or off I prefer to keep it on
and the Delta strength you know either
one or two you know I don't really get
into you know strengths of three four or
five or anything like that but me I tend
to keep it at one but you know after
talking to a few people recently I'm
seriously considering two as well you
know on other charts so again you know
it really comes down to your risk
appetite I mean that's what that's what
people don't understand it is think well
you know I
to start trading and they don't have the
mental makeup or you know I see that all
the time you know people think that
every trade on order flow that they take
has to be a winner no you know it's not
like you know you go to the bar to you
know with your mindset I'm going to go
meet a woman tonight you know and it's
gonna be the one I'm gonna marry
no you know on the first time you got
it's not like that
right it's a numbers game in a sense you
kind of keep going back till you find
the right one unfortunately but and in
trading is the same way so don't get
caught up in the thinking that oh I
gotta have 80% winners all I gotta have
90% winners and if I don't it's it's a
scam it's a failure no it's it's not you
know the Pareto principle 80% of your
profits will come from 20% of your
trades and that's just how life goes
sometimes so you know if you found this
helpful great if not okay you know you
don't write nasty comments on here you
know just say you know a thumbs up or
whatever I don't care I do this for my
own self and you know I do it for the
users of my tools so thanks everyone
have a great day bye bye